outlines the details of the crash we
have team coverage for you on this
monday afternoon but first we're sending
it out to jeremy j4 jeremy
that's right christian i am here at
north las vegas airport and at the site
of sunday's deadly plane crash as you
guys can see behind me there's still the
remains of the cessna 172 that's sitting
on the side of this hill as it had
collided with the piper meridian in
midair
right now
two small airplanes were coming in for a
final landing at the same time one was
the land on runway 3-0 left and the
other on 3-0 right unfortunately both
aircraft attempted to land on the same
runway causing a collision dory rodin a
local pilot says landing at the north
las vegas airport can be very dangerous
i have my plane hangered here and
there's a lot of traffic so it's always
a concern about you know how well the
airport system and
flights are managed coming in and out of
the airport
so the four passengers that were in the
two different planes are currently dead